i think what what has really allowed me
to be where i am is that
if if i may be so spiritual here i think
that
that um it is my recognition that what i
am more so than anything else is a
spiritual being
and so my quest is for my spiritual
involvement my spiritual development and
everything else seems to fall into place
oprah winfrey thought the color purple
was her big break
little did she know she was about to
become a phenomenon
so i think my greatest gift is my
ability to be myself on camera
only e.t was with oprah from the start
and she could feel that the big screen
adaptation of alice walker's book
would be life-changing you know i
usually work
work on on a level where i'm just just
on a cloud now at nine
i'm i'm soaring above 27 now really
that's that's how my life has changed i
mean just total total total excitement
all the time
just don't make me wait too long hoppo i
was born
to act i was born to act and i always
knew that i would be an actress
always did when i was growing up on the
farm in mississippi and was sitting on
in the pig pen talking to those pigs
because it was just my grandmother and
myself
and i used to know i used to do little
plays and little skits with him and
i knew i knew that i would be the role
of sophia was an
incredible gift for the up-and-coming
talk show host the character symbolized
the obstacles she herself had overcome
to me she represents the bridges that
i've crossed over on to get to where i
am now
i have been working and waiting 31 years
to get to this moment
so having been born on a farm in
mississippi born from a broken home and
all those other things you know that
people like to talk about
all of that has made me what i am
yes silly everything want to be loved
this isn't a movie about black people if
you change the color of the skins of all
of us on there you'd have the same story
this is this is a story about a woman's
quest for her own
self it's about self-discovery it's
about uh
the human spirit it's about endurance
it's about survival ultimately about
faith it's about celie discovering that
the power to be whatever she wants to be
in her life
doesn't lie in other people she
understands as the movie says god gets
pissed if you don't notice the color
purple
that's what this movie is about less
than a year after the movie's release
oprah celebrated the national debut of
the oprah winfrey show
things are going pretty good for me
right now i've been in television since
i was 19 years old so i've been warming
up for a while
i think that what's happening to me is
is exactly what's supposed to be
happening to me i'm delighted i'm joyful
and i
every day is a celebration for me but
i'm not really surprised
oprah went on to co-produce a successful
adaptation of the color purple for
broadway
and decades after her breakout
performance oprah
still holds the experience dear all love
it's where i discovered love what it
means to love your work what it means to
love friends what it means to be to be
impassioned by work
[Music]
you